incident is unique it's not [ __ ]
unique it's not George Floyd happened
there's not even enough room on a
t-shirt to put all the names if you
wrote it in but I think batches chest
you can start no I'll tell you I love
King bass he's actually a really good
dude yeah he is a good dude but okay man
I got to tell you something black
Twitter or [ __ ] rip that boy off I
cry when they so hard
Jesus and then you know what's ahead of
you this one little tattoo but the time
this sucks it's in five minutes I almost
passed out when he started doing the
curb on the L right all the name come on
oh Jesus my keeping it real goes wrong
like at what point did you know he's
like a walking kill mugger and I know he
meant well my brother I know you meant
well funny thing is like what I thought
Tamar rice I was like I was like yo what
is going on bro it's like did you have a
light go right that [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
would have been hilarious and the funny
thing it was like I couldn't stop
laughing just said it with his chest
like literally when I saw how red his
chest was 86 tanks and within those 86
takes nobody told them bro this is a bad
idea
you know what this reminds me of see
this is the times when you find out who
your real friends are right between the
eighty-six fakes nobody telling him that
he was wrong was the same thing when
little Kim came out with that song when
she decided to have a patois accent
all those people in the studio and
nobody so this was a bad idea
you need new friends you need new if
kylie jenner's friends were able to keep
that baby a secret with them because
they keep it real you know it was just
watching that baby why don't you tell
him because he didn't he didn't confide
in me plus I'm an Asian the guy you like
I know I don't have a say in this [ __ ]
and so like when I was watching it right
and and it took me about 36 times just
to watch it all the way through let it
do the part you gonna learn today so
crazy that was a point where I was
watching this [ __ ] right and I was like
okay I like King [ __ ] because he has a
young audience and there's a young so
there's a young audience and a lot of
white people that fall that people need
to hear this stuff right but the moment
he came on and I was like oh he's doing
spoken word I was like okay spoken word
is a very difficult thing to tackle
let's see if he could do that and then
he wrote [ __ ] a brand deal I was like
first of all [ __ ] that's the
most best what you need though that's
like the most socially distance thing
I've ever heard of because what didn't
the [ __ ] are you talking about right now
like people understand your plight of
not taking a brand deal of a million
dollars like come on bro like patch I
Love You Man but somebody in your circle
should have told you people can't relate
to that [ __ ] dude
hey and then he said this I've never
heard a black male ever say this in my
life he said kick rocks
tik-tok kick kick rocks I was like bro
that is the weakest line I've ever heard
of my life and I want to tell you
something man I love you like I
appreciate you so [ __ ] much what
you've done for social media people on
this platform and saying what you had to
say but when your chest turn bright
cherry red you didn't take a break in
between takes to let that inflammation
calm down nobody and the ointment
I wanted to ask him like so one of his
other friends tonight was thinning a
group thread you know like it was like
look at this yeah I'm not gonna say the
word but look at me get Cleveland locked
out no let me refill my wine well I mean
when I'm talking about the whole batch
situation is because I'm only I'm also
talking about just like social media
people are celebrities who feel like
they have to say something let me tell
you something about that celebrity
[ __ ] video while I appreciate you
forsaking it for whatever reason first
of all I want to see the receipts right
because I want to know the brand that
said hey if you support your culture you
you will not get this check do you see
what I'm saying it's like that's an
example of like just a little bit just a
little and I want to sound like I said
I'm not [ __ ] on the dude like I'm
his biggest [ __ ] supporter but
because I'm your big supporter doesn't
mean that you can't hold them
accountable like grab words me think if
you support black people we're not
giving you a million not have you Brett
yeah nobody said no exactly the KKK my
who was it who is your brand support who
said it there was another girl named
Leanne who I actually very much liked to
write and she did a version of what
batch did but what she did was she did a
stop-motion thing where she wrote like
BLM and then she was doing - what's
wrong with the world mama people hate
and so I watched this Abby yeah she
she's black mr. Leaphart she's just like
just watching that [ __ ] and she got
roast is so hard because of that it's
like you didn't watch batch of [ __ ] and
you as a Filipino woman thought you were
gonna get away with it you have any idea
I know for a fact because that will stop
motion and you had to do every single
letter
[ __ ] that took you six days you did a
six-day mistake I think what people
forget is because the dragging that went
on like I couldn't even make it the
reason I couldn't even make it through
the whole video was because here I'm
tick-tock with kick rocks threads in the
comments good like Vasiliy that's what
black twitter truly exists for it's not
necessarily the original post
it's the comment yeah man I literally
told Khalif well looking at that video
it looked like that [ __ ] fell
asleep on a pile of newspapers you know
this whole video is just gonna be called
roasted king bed no I mean he he meant
well see as a teacher I'm always able to
try and validate people's actions yeah
because I have to understand what 10
year-olds think so he meant well you
know were safer let's just keep him in
art let's keep him lifted in prayer yeah
okay I don't know how he's gonna recover
from this it's so weird just watching
just watching that [ __ ] and I'm like
people understands like man you roast
people a lot it's like cuz I had to I
grew up in a black community so if I
didn't come quick with it I would have
just been the loser in the group you
want to tell the people what I said
about you oh yeah go ahead that David is
a black a 40 year old black woman that
had his prime in the 90s he was walking
around with like you have to dress
the silk wrap nails the waterfall the
waterfalls you had the swoop bank and a
French roll that is your prime huh you
talking about literally you talk about
like literally half the custom